es begann alles mit einem tweet ihnen
macht stand in einem dieser schlimmen
staus in los angeles in denen einfach
nichts mehr geht er war genervt und in
diesem moment hatte er offensichtlich
seine nächste bahnbrechende idee verkehr
macht mich wahnsinnig ich wäre eine
tunnelbohrmaschine bauen und einfach los
graben
das war im dezember 2006 sind also von
kurzem und jetzt ist die firma gegründet
und es wird bereits gebohrt wie das
ganze aussieht jetzt endlich zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
im dezember 2005 den habe ich das
riesenglück dabei zu sein als ihnen
mafia in berlin vor einer kleinen schar
zuhörer mit dem damaligen
bundeswirtschaftsminister sigmar gabriel
über die zukunft von elektroautos
braucht ganz anders als die jobs mit dem
wir ja immer wieder verglichen wird ist
ein ganz ruhiger charakter und wirkt so
gar nicht charismatisch dabei scheint
ihr die leitlinie von steve jobs eins zu
eins umzusetzen
henri de toulouse bleibt hungrig bleibt
tollkühn und er geht dabei vielleicht
sogar noch weiter als sonst am anfang
muteten ja die ersten tests noch als
spielerei für superreiche an für die
geld einfach überhaupt keine rolle
spielt die waren unvernünftig schnell
verbrauchen viel strom aber waren
technisch allen anderen elektroautos
finde ich weit voraus endlich mal
batterien die nicht nach 20 km
alle waren und nach einem jahr in den
müll gehörten ich kann davon echten
liebling ich hatte so einige
elektroautos aber dann machte er die
fahrzeuge auch noch massentauglich und
ist dabei den markt für pkw umzukrempeln
inzwischen alle großen autohersteller
nach es geschieht genau das gleiche was
jobs mit dem telefonmarkt gemacht hat
nur mit einem ungleich schwierigeren und
wichtigen produkt wahnsinn wenn sex sein
nächster kurier krempelt er die
raumfahrt komplett um und senkt die
kosten durch wiederverwendbare
raketenstufen dramatisch will vom ball
zu rüsten um den mond schicken und
menschen auf dem mars landen lassen er
zeigt schon jetzt dass er ganze staaten
mit seinen projekten in den schatten
stellen kann
australien hat er versprochen die
energieprobleme des landes innerhalb von
100 tagen zu lösen
das land hat sofort reagiert und einen
von mask angebotenen energiespeicher
ausgeschrieben
das müssen schlafen sie können nicht
einfach so eine firma beauftragen die
chancen stehen also nicht schlecht das
macht hier zum zuge kommt halten
das neue transportmittel dass menschen
wie in einer rohrpost schneller als mit
dem flugzeug zwischen großen städten
transportieren soll
ja das gibt es ja auch noch und jetzt
sein neuestes projekt und ich finde es
wirklich gejagt es sind ein paar
wirklich bahnbrechende ideen enthalten
so gibt es keine herkömmlichen
tunneleinfahrten die wagen fahren
einfach von der straße
der aufzug in den tunnel werden
abgesetzt und dann auf einer plattform
zu ihrem zielort transportiert es gibt
keinen zusätzlichen platz auch unzählige
probleme wurden damit auf einmal gelöst
wer ist er wirklich unglaublich nicht
einfach tunnel in dem sich der verkehr
dann wieder staut sondern letztlich ein
geregelter bahnverkehr computergesteuert
so können die kapazitäten der tolle viel
besser ausgenutzt werden
die plattform fahren auf schienen und
werden mit strom betrieben
der diesel pkw verpesten dort unten dann
die luft nicht be- und entlüftung ist
viel einfacher und das beste die
geschwindigkeit mit 200 kilometern pro
stunde durch die stadt
genial und die tunnelbohrmaschine dafür
habe auch schon seine niveau als die
bohrmaschine seiner boeing company
zuvor hatte auch noch dort bereits unter
dem gelände von spacex das besondere sie
bohrt und verstärkt die tunnelwand in
einem
es kann also viel viel effektiver
gebohrt werden
die frage ist also nur wie viele
maschinen man einsetzt umso mehr bohren
desto schneller ist ein ganzes kümmel
netz unter einer stadt fertig so und das
ist das nächste projekt familie matschig
wird er sofort wissen
okay noch gibt es nichts neues aber wenn
es soweit ist erfahrt ihr es hier mit
als erste brücke dafür hier genau ein
abo aufs auge
und vergesst mich dem aus die glocke
hier sind übrigens die anderen videos
von mir über projekte von ihnen macht
einfach nur der wahnsinnig drauf wenn er
nochmal die hy lake gold und es sind
immer highlights wenn ihnen was dabei
ist also ansonsten gesamtrang